I actually don't care whether or not
officially becomes part of the immunity
as far as I'm concerned it already is
and every time you go to Turkey you see
more and more waves in which its
European izing it's a process that's
been going on for over 40 years the fact
is that Europe that Turkey is almost
fully integrated into the European
economy there's plenty of obstacles
still in the way there is a variety of
non-tariff barriers and quotas and other
mechanisms that slow down the free
exchange between Turkey and Europe but
the volume of investment from Europe
into Turkey is absolutely enormous it's
far larger than from the United States
or Russia or anyone else for that matter
and the number of Turks living in Europe
and earning money there and sending it
back to Turkey is also enormous it's
it's well over a billion dollars a year
in capital that comes back so in all of
the important tangible ways turkey
already is very European in all of the
less important but politically symbolic
waves like whether or not it happens to
be a member of the EU or not it isn't a
member it is a distinction without